while it's great that we can query our
database through the content provider it
would be nice if we could also use the
content provider to put data in we'll
begin with the insert function let's
fill the insert function with the same
URI matcher code we have in the other
content provider functions but with one
change we're only going to match the
base URI x' there's a good reason for
this when we insert into our database we
wanted to notify every Content observer
that might have data modified by our
insert it turns out that cursors
registered themselves as notify for
descendants which means that notifying
the root URI will also notify all
descendants of that URI if we were to
notify based on anything else other than
the root URI then a cursor listening on
the root URI will not get notified of a
change that would certainly impact it so
we have to be very careful when doing
that for this reason it makes a lot of
sense to only allow insertions at our
root URI into our database that way it's
very very easy to handle notifications
it means that we also don't have to
build a combination query for our insert
containing a parameter coming from the
URI with the rest of the parameters
coming from a function so for whether we
just pass the parameters into a database
insert call we should throw an exception
if the insert fails the only trick here
is to make sure we return the correct
value which is a URI
fortunately we made a function to build
these URIs which contain the whether
path followed by an ID let's go test
this once again we go to a test provider
and we modify our test because after all
it's supposed to be test insert read
provider here's our insert statement
obviously it's still talking to the
database we're going to want to make it
talk to the provider as always that's
pretty straightforward we always get our
provider by using our content resolver
so we can replace this insert statement
with the DB with a content resolver
instead and of course we don't use a
Content resolver against a table name
instead we do it against the weather
entry dot content URI but there's still
something wrong of course
we don't actually return the weather row
ID we return a URI but we can still get
a weather row in D how do we do that
quite simply using a helper function in
content URIs and we don't really need
that insert after all we know that this
Content resolver function isn't actually
going to return unless the value is true
now that we finish that let's run the
test and make sure that we can actually
insert using our content provider and
our test pass well you know what time it
is time for you to write some of this as
well